bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans cette nouvelle vidéo aujourd'hui on
va parler d'une théorie que j'ai en tête
depuis quand même pas mal de temps
depuis plusieurs mois mais voilà
j'estime qu'aujourd'hui c'est le bon
moment on va parler de thor 4 love and
thunder et sincèrement je préfère vous
prévenir d' avance mais il y a de très
grandes chances que cette théorie
vieillissent très mal alors pourquoi me
direz-vous tout simplement car on va
s'intéresser à l'origine story de gore
pour le mc eu gore sera amenée dans thor
4 love and thunder est évidemment bas il
ya de grandes chances que tous on bat g
soit amené avec dans tous les cas ce
sera à vous de me dire ce que vous en
pensez n'hésitez pas à vous abonner à la
chaîne si ce n'est pas encore déjà fait
on s'approche dangereusement des cent
mille abonnés donc voilà un très grand
merci à vous pour votre soutien et puis
bah écoute et ne tardons pas plus
longtemps let's go si je vous disais que
les célestes ont inconsciemment créé
gore le boucher des dieux est ce que
vous croyez cette idée possible
comme vous le savez les célestes et
notamment à rich ème place dans les
planètes des graines qui un beau jour
environ un milliard d'années plus tard
deviendront des nouveaux céleste qui
aideront à raychem à réguler la vie dans
l'univers les planètes qui ont été
choisies pour accueillir ses futurs
nouveaux céleste ne sont pas aléatoires
évidemment ce sont des planètes capable
d'accueillir la vie cette même vie qui
permettra de fournir assez d'énergie
pour donner naissance au céleste en
incubation dans la planète c'est le
phénomène d'émergence dont nous avons
été témoins dans le film d éternel sauf
que pour que l'émergence se lance il
faut que la vie se développe de façon
conséquente sur une planète il faut que
la vie soit abondante afin de fournir
assez d'énergie au céleste en incubation
pour qu'ils puissent naître et c'est là
le point intéressant même si art et shem
et les célestes réguler la vie dans
l'univers eh bien ils ne sont pas
toujours maître de ce qu'ils ont créé la
vie se régule beaucoup d'elle-même et
par conséquent c'est la naissance aussi
d'un équilibre où les planètes abritant
la vie possède des prédateurs qui se
nourrissent d'autres êtres vivants et
cetera et cetera
du coup à raychem afin de permettre le
développement accru de forme de vie
intelligente a donné naissance aux
éternels c'est ce qui nous est expliqué
dans le film les éternels ont pour but
de guider l'humanité à se développer
afin de pouvoir enclencher l'émergence
et la naissance du céleste thiam août
néanmoins ce n'est pas la première
solution car il m a trouvé les éternels
ont été créés est programmé pour contrer
les déviants et c'est à ce moment que la
théorie véritable commence quant à rich
m explique à cercy ses origines il lui
dévoile qu'il garde les souvenirs des
éternels en réserve pour étudier les
déviants les déviants ont en fait été
créée par arrêt gm lui même bien avant
les éternels le problème était que les
planètes habitants les graines céleste
posséder des prédateurs qui empêchait le
bon développement de la vie intelligente
et donc qui empêchait l'émergence arish
m a donc donné naissance aux déviants
afin de devenir des prédateurs pour les
prédateurs empêchant la vie de se
développer sauf que comme il le dit lui
même sa création était imparfaite et au
final les déviants ont évolué et sont
devenus des prédateurs encore plus
dangereux et plus néfaste que les
prédateurs de base de la planète harish
m n'avait plus aucun contrôle sur eux
les déviants sont donc la plus grande
erreur d'art et shem et les éternels ont
pour mission de la corriger maintenant
vous allez me dire bon bah voilà c'est
bien cet intéressant tout ça mais au
final quel est le rapport avec gore et
bien je vous dirais qu'une erreur d'une
échelle cosmique peut avoir de très
lourdes conséquences sur l'univers et la
vie en général
si on s'intéresse aux petites lignes de
ce que nous dévoile à raychem cela
signifie qu'il a parasité plusieurs
planètes et donc la vie en général avec
la naissance de ces fameux d'evian bien
avant que les éternels soit créé
programme est pire que ça arrêt chez
nous dit qu'il se sert des souvenirs des
éternels afin d'étudier les déviants qui
ne cesse d'évoluer ce qui peut vouloir
dire également qu'il a observé le
comportement des déviants en train de
dévaster la vie présente sur des
planètes pour mieux les contrecarrer
pour les futures autres émergence avec
la naissance des éternels sauf que qui
au final subi les expériences ratées
d'art et shem et bien ce sont les
habitants de la planète évidemment
et là il faut que nous nous tournions
vers l'origine story de gore le boucher
des dieux
[Musique]
gore avant de devenir ce qu'il deviendra
est à la base la représentation la plus
banale de ce que l'on peut catégoriser
de forme de vie intelligente si on
reprend les mots d'harish m il est
présenté comme un extraterrestre dont la
race est inconnue il vient d'une planète
qui n'a même pas de nom tout ça pour
dire qu'à la base il n'est rien et il
vient de nulle part il symbolise juste
une forme de vie intelligente comme une
autre l'unique particularité du peuple
de gore c'est que l'on sait qu'il fait
partie d'une race extraterrestre qui est
très pieuse ces derniers possèdent
beaucoup de croyances il pris
constamment les dieux et pour cause la
planète sur laquelle ils vivent est
particulièrement hostile les ressources
se font rares les catastrophes
naturelles sont nombreuses et de
nombreux prédateurs menace constamment
la tribu de gore les prières sont donc
un moyen de garder l'espoir de trouver
la force de survivre c'est la seule
chose qu'ils ont après tout mais c'est
là que tout va se jouer pour gore et
qu'il peut y avoir une réadaptation pour
le mc car dans les comics à cause de
l'hostilité de la planète gore va perdre
tour à tour les membres de sa famille
ses parents sa femme enceinte et même
ses enfants malmenés par le destin et la
perte de ses proches gore va commencer à
douter de l'existence même des dieux un
élément qui le poussera à l'exil car sa
tribu verra d'un mauvais oeil cette
rébellion et c'est lors de son
bannissement qu'il sera témoin d'une
confrontation entre deux divinités qui
se blesseront mortellement et là c'est
la révélation pour gore les dieu existe
véritablement est pire que ça il existe
mais en plus ils n'ont jamais répondu à
ces prières ou à celle de son peuple ils
n'ont jamais aidé gore alors que s'ils
étaient intervenus peut-être que sa
famille ferait encore partie de ce monde
aujourd'hui la suite vous la connaissez
certainement parmi ce combat opposant
les deux divinités se trouvait nulle le
créateur des symbiote et possesseur de
larmes symbiote all blacks donnés
crossword qui s'attachera à gore le
faisant devenir le futur massacreur de
dieu car après avoir réalisé que les
dieux existait et qu'en plus il ne
l'avait jamais et des gorges jura de
partir en quête de tuer tous les dieux
de l'univers maintenant concernant le mc
hugh je trouve qu'il ya vraiment pas mal
de choses intéressantes à dire comme
vous le savez dans le mc eu tout est
interconnecté
on a beau suivre les aventures de spider
man des gardiens de la galaxie
des éternels peu importe il y a toujours
des éléments ou des petits détails qui
relie tout ça est un autre élément qui
est très important à souligner c'est que
le film des éternels redistribue toutes
les cartes c'est même kevin fait guy le
papa du mc uc il le dit lui même il y a
clairement un avant et un après eternalz
pourquoi cela me direz vous et bien tout
simplement car désormais les éternels
amène le passé historique de l'histoire
cosmique du mc eu les fondements de
l'univers en gros sans oublier
évidemment tout ce côté divinité
cosmique que l'on connaît encore très
peu depuis le début nous suivons les
aventures de thor mais il est très loin
d'être le seul dieu de l'univers marvel
c'est idiot à dire mais aujourd'hui nous
avons carrément les éternels et en plus
les célestes qui ont un impact sur tout
ce qui est cosmique et tout ça là cela
colle parfaitement avec l'histoire de
gore pour rentrer plus particulièrement
dans la théorie il est difficile de
définir véritablement l'âge de gore car
dans les comics all blacks venaient
crossword lui permet d'atteindre une
certaine immortalité mais nous savons
qu'il est très vieux si dès le début du
film il est déjà en quête de tuer tous
les dieux sait qu'il a déjà atteint une
très longue de longévité mais bon tout
ça ce n'est qu'un détail ce que je veux
dire c'est que gore et s'attribue sont
probablement les victimes des erreurs
d'harish m en donnant naissance aux
déviants dont il a perdu le contrôle
bien avant la création des éternels
arish m à saccager la vie d'innombrables
personnes incapables de faire face à ces
fameux d'evian qui ont évolué et qui
sont devenus des prédateurs féroces et
pris le dessus sur la vie présente de la
planète le truc à presse qu'il faut
quand même qu'il y à un moyen pour gore
de prendre conscience que les divinités
existent et qu'ils trouvent également ce
fameux pouvoir qui va permettre de se
confronter à ces derniers mais dans tous
les cas dans son histoire il y a de très
fortes chances qu'il ait pris conscience
des atrocités qu'ont effectué les
célestes j'aimerais que vous vous
rappeliez d'essonne le chercheur le
fameux céleste qui a vaporisé une
planète entière grâce à la pierre du
pouvoir imaginer un seul instant qu à
cause de l'erreur d'harish m d'avoir
anéanti les équilibres de la vie parce
qu'il a amené les déviances sur
certaines planètes essonne le chercheur
étaient envoyés pour justement vaporiser
ces planètes car de toute façon elle
était condamnée et jamais les graines de
céleste implantées dans ces dernières
pourraient un jour devenir de nouveaux
céleste la planète de gore pourrait être
victime de ce genre d'action suite à son
bannissement il aurait pu trouver le
moyen par exemple de quitter la planète
mais en revenant ils auraient été
témoins que cette dernière aurait été
vaporisé par les célestes créant en lui
cette fameuse haine envers ces divinités
dans tous les cas il est clair que gore
aura une dent contre les célestes et les
éternels qu'il soit bon ou mauvais il
reste des divinités des dieux et par
conséquent ils sont les ennemis de gore
par définition sincèrement le massacreur
de dieu serait même un bon moyen de
réunir tort les gardiens de la galaxie
car évidemment on sait qu'ils feront un
bout de chemin avec le dieu du tonnerre
mais aussi avec les éternels pour un
premier contact
en vrai même si l'idée que les célestes
et créer inconsciemment gore et que cela
ait développé chez lui cette fameuse
haine envers les divinités
plutôt pertinente il faut quand même
garder en tête que c'est possible que
tout ça n'arrive pas du tout il faut le
rappeler avant caudin ne soit dépeint
comme un roi d'asgard prônant la paix et
la protection il était à la base un
conquérant se servant de sa fille hélas
comme d'une arme afin d'asservir les
autres royaumes gore pourrait faire
partie d'un de ces peuples asservis et
je me permets de citer une phrase du
film the batman les péchés du père
retomberont sur son fils d'ailleurs le
pouvoir d là était une réadaptation dole
blakeney crossword larmes de
prédilection de gore dans les comics
donc il peut y avoir des liens entre
tout ça mais n'oubliez jamais que nous
sommes dans le mc eu et que tout est
possible même si les films suivent
souvent une trame importante de
l'histoire des comics je me permets de
faire la métaphore mais c'est comme si
les comics était une sorte de
garde-manger rempli d'ingrédients et le
marvel cinématiques unis versent choisi
certains ingrédients justement pour
former le plat
j'espère en tout cas sincèrement que ma
vidéo vous aura plu je sais que le film
des éternels divise beaucoup mais
personnellement j'aime beaucoup cette
thématique d' entité cosmique âgé de
plusieurs milliers d'années voire de
millions d'années concernant les
célestes il faut que le mc hugh avance
il faut que le mcs renouvelle et il est
totalement clair que les éternels vont
amener beaucoup de changements pour
l'avenir n'oubliez pas le petit pouce
bleus c'est très important pour soutenir
mon travail et surtout si la vidéo vous
a plu un bien évidemment n'hésitez pas
non plus à laisser un petit commentaire
je sais pas vous mais moi franchement
l'arrivée de gore c'est quelque chose
qui me lie peut vraiment beaucoup c'est
sûr et certain que marvel va réécrire
beaucoup de choses concernant son
histoire et va vraiment y avoir une
réadaptation mai
c'est ça qui me rend curieux je suis
vraiment curieux de voir ce qu'ils vont
nous proposer n'hésitez pas non plus à
vous abonner pour ne pas louper les
prochaines vidéos il ya clairement
énormément théorie à faire cette année
on a beaucoup de travail et j'espère de
tout coeur être à la hauteur de vos
espérances d'ailleurs j'en profite je
place la mais pour ceux qui aiment bien
les mystères et les théories entourant
les célestes je vous conseille la vidéo
que j'ai sorti il ya pas si longtemps
concernant l'arrivée de galactus bref
que le lionheart soit avec vous c'était
un plaisir de vous faire cette vidéo et
puis voilà à la prochaine
cet argot rock cha où tout le monde
[Musique]